every living being needs to fight off
for other living beings that want to
feast on them so as multicellular life
evolved over billions of years it came
up with ways to defend itself today
humans have a sophisticated defense
network like physical barriers defense
cells and weapons factories but one of
the most important defenses of our body
is largely unknown the complement system
it evolved over 700 million years ago
and is an army of over 30 different
proteins that work together in a complex
and elegant dance to stop intruders
all in all about 15 quintillion of them
are saturating every fluid in your body
right now
guided by nothing but chemistry these
proteins are one of the most effective
weapons we have against invaders many
other parts of the immune system are
just tools to activate the complement
system but it's also really dangerous
imagine having trillions of little bombs
inside your blood that could go off at
any moment so our cells use numerous
mechanisms to prevent complement from
accidentally attacking them okay what
exactly does it do and what makes it so
dangerous
[Music]
in a nutshell the complement system does
three things it cripples enemies it
activates the immune system and it rips
holes in things until they die
but how after all these are mindless
proteins randomly drifting around
without where law direction well this is
actually part of the strategy complement
proteins float around in a sort of
passive mode they do nothing until they
get activated and change their shape in
the world of proteins your shape
determines what you can and cannot do
because shape determines what you can
interact with and in what way for
example in your passive shape you might
do nothing in your active shape however
you might for example change the shape
of other proteins activating them so
they can activate others mechanisms like
this one can start cascades that spread
very quickly
imagine the complement proteins as being
like millions of matches very close
together once one catches fire it
ignites the ones around it they ignite
more and suddenly you have a big fire to
show the actual mechanisms of the
complement system is a tad complicated
and overwhelming so we'll simplify here
now let's imagine you cut yourself and a
bunch of bacteria enter the wound and
make it into the surrounding tissue our
complement attack begins with c3 c3 is
the first match the initial spark that
will start our fire and to do that
c3 needs to switch from passive to
active how this happens is complex but
let's just say it can happen randomly
through other complement proteins that
bind to enemies or through antibodies
all you really need to know is that c3
breaks into two smaller proteins c3a and
c3b that are now activated one of these
parts for c3 B protein is like a seeker
miss are specialized in bacteria fungi
and viruses it has a fraction of a
second to find a victim or it will be
neutralized by
water molecules if c3b does find a
target it anchors itself very tightly to
its surface and doesn't let go by doing
so the protein changes its shape again
in its new shape it's now able to grab
other proteins and start a small cascade
changing its shape multiple times adding
other complement proteins to itself he
finally it transforms itself into a
recruiting platform known as c3
convertase this platform is an expert at
activating more c3 proteins that start
the whole cycler new an amplification
loop begins soon thousands of proteins
cover the bacteria for the bacteria this
is very bad it can [ __ ] the bacteria
and make them helpless or slow them down
imagine being covered by thousands of
flies but there's more do you remember
the other part of c3 the c3 a protein
c3a is like a distress beacon thousands
of them flood away from the site of
battle screaming for attention passive
immune cells notice the c3 a proteins
and awakened from their slumber to
follow the protein tracks to the site of
infection the more alarm proteins they
encounter the more aggressive they get
this way complement guides
reinforcements exactly to the place
where they're needed the most so far the
complement has slowed down the invaders
and called for help now it's beginning
to actively help to kill the enemy the
first immune cells to arrive at the
battlefield of phagocytes which means
cells that swallow you whole
trap you in a tiny prison and then kill
you with acid but to swallow an enemy
they need to grab it first which is not
easy because bacteria prefer not to be
grabbed and a sort of slippery but now
the complement that has anchored itself
to the bacteria acts as a sort of glue
that makes it easy for the immune cells
to catch their victims but it gets even
better
imagine being covered in flies again now
imagine them turning into wasps
another cascade is about to begin on the
surface of a bacteria the c3 recruitment
platform changes its shape again and
begins to recruit new proteins together
they begin the construction of a bigger
structure a membrane attack complex
piece-by-piece new proteins shaped like
long Spears anchor themselves deep into
the bacteria's membranes until they rip
a hole into them that can't be closed
again fluids rush into the bacteria and
their insides spill out they lead to
death the remaining bacteria are maimed
and distracted by the complement and
quickly taken care of by the arriving
immune cells the invasion has been
nipped in the bud before it had the
opportunity to become dangerous you
probably didn't even notice it but while
bacteria are not happy about complement
the enemies it might be the most useful
against are actually viruses viruses
have one problem they need to travel
from cell to cell outside of cells
they're basically hoping to randomly
bump against a cell to infect by pure
chance here they're completely
defenseless and here complement is able
to intercept and [ __ ] them so they
become harmless and guide the immune
system to devour them without complement
virus infections would be a lot more
deadly but wait if we have such an
effective weapon why do we ever get sick
the problem is that in a war both sides
adapt for example when the vaccinia
virus infects a cell it forces it to
produce a protein that shuts complement
activation down this way the virus
creates safe zones around the cells it
infects when it kills them and tries to
infect more it has a higher chance of
being successful or some bacteria for
example can grab certain molecules from
the blood but keep the complement system
calm and make themselves invisible so
the complement system while being
extremely important is only one player
in the complex
and a beautiful organization that is our
immune system a beautiful example of how
many mindless things can do smart things
together this video was sponsored by you
without your direct support this channel
would not exist and it's hard to
overstate how grateful we are that in
2019 an average courts cos alpha do took
at least 1200 hours to produce we need
months to research and write our scripts
clear them with experts illustrate and
animate every scene from scratch and to
compose original music this is only
possible through a combination of
sponsorships your support on patreon and
selling merch like this poster and
postcards we made about the complement
system if you yourself want to support
us you can do so by watching becoming a
patreon and maybe getting a personal
bird all by getting one of our calendars
or posters the purpose of court schizont
is to make the best videos we can and to
make science more approachable thank you
so much for making this possible
[Music]